I've gotten into the habit each month of
shooting one of these sort of sum up of
the previous month what's coming up in
the next month types of videos that I
call updates and I'm providing these for
my my viewers and subscribers so that
they can stay on top of anything that
they might missed that they might find
interesting and they want to go back to
usually I'll try to provide some links
but you know where to find things if you
if you played around on the channel and
I want to give a sort of heads up about
about things that are coming up in the
current month of things to look out for
since I know everybody is very busy one
of the things that I do want to mention
before I talk about the month of
februari is a few of the things that are
coming up in in March we're actually
doing something quite new that we're
calling a meet-up it's actually under
the philosophy eats title which we used
for some some events previously but this
this fits as well we're going to do
meetups quarterly where viewers
subscribers people who follow me on
other pages like my facebook page or my
google plus profile or Twitter or are
connected with me on linkedin or any
these sorts of things can actually meet
me face to face and talk philosophy chat
about other things if they want to as
well this first one we're actually going
to be having here in Kingston New York
we're going to do it at at panera which
is on the north side of Kingston if you
know Kingston at all I'll put a lot more
information about this actually there's
already a Google+ site for it Google+
event and it'll be on Sunday March 16th
all the information that's relevant is
available in the Google+ event so I'm
really looking forward to that I always
enjoy I've done this a few other times
but just one on one I always enjoy
meeting people who like these videos and
get something out of them and getting to
chat with them finding
what they're doing with philosophy how
philosophy is impacting their life
because I'm all about philosophy into
practice that's the model for for reason
I oh we we don't want it to just be a
purely theoretical activity we want it
to be something that in rich's people's
lives so that's one thing we've got
going on I'm going to be doing another
dr. Sanders philosophy forum as well
this is going to be a little bit
different as well because I'm bringing
in a guest this time a friend and
colleague of mine from who I know from
from Alistair McIntyre circles who works
on virtue ethics and a number of other
things really brilliant guy and I'll put
up with information about that as well
also be doing another one of the
glimpses into existence at the kingston
public library on march 29th so if
you're in the local area and would like
to get some philosophical stimulation on
a Saturday morning that's that's a good
place to go if you live in the
mid-hudson area consider stopping in now
let's talk about februari so februari
was a pretty pretty packed month for for
me and for my wife and partner i'll tell
you a little bit why on her part towards
towards the end of this um I gave a talk
out at solvay Regina University in
newport rhode island i was invited to
address the Pell honor students by a
good friend and colleague of mine Khalil
who brought me in this has been quite a
while in the making he if you watched
the video for it he's the guy at the
very beginning of the video who's doing
the introduction and they asked me to do
a talk about neech's early work the
birth of tragedy so that's exactly what
I did and it was a lot of fun beautiful
campus very motivated students good
question answer period I had a great
time out there and I'm very grateful
that they they brought me out to do that
talk just before that we had been up at
Green Mountain College in
Vermont my wife mashaka is the Center
for the excellence in teaching and
learning at the Culinary Institute of
America and so I was sort of tagging
along on that one because there is green
mountain is billed as the greenest
college or university in the United
States and they have a lot of things
having to do with environmental studies
but also with Food Network's and so the
culinary has a big interest in that in
sort of tapping into their masters
program and while I was up there it was
really cool there's a couple fellow SIU
grads that's where i went to my graduate
school southern illinois university
there there's several of them up there
and so it was a good time to sort of
reconnect and talk about perhaps coming
up to do some some other talks or
workshops or things like that on my part
for their students i'm also i also had a
great time talking with the master
students who were there we drove up
through a snowstorm so we made just the
hind end of the conference but we got to
go to you know one of the workshops and
the dinner and get to meet and talk with
some very interesting people so that was
a lot of fun shortly after all of that
that was all in one week of februari i
did the second installment of the
glimpses into existence series at the
kingston public library the this is a
series that's going to run the entire
year one per month usually the last
saturday of the month and this year the
theme is 11 existentialist authors since
I'm doing a lot of work on
existentialism these days and the first
one in January began a sort of a general
overview the second one focused on
certain Kierkegaard his work is
influenced some of his key ideas the
video for that's available and you can
you can watch it of course in my channel
i'll link to it here oh and we did of
course a doctor sailors philosophy for
him a little bit earlier in the month
that was a lot of fun I
these are Google Hangouts on air that I
do where I can get some interaction from
my subscribers or viewers or people who
follow me asking questions making
comments wanting me to talk about this
or that and Plato and what we focused on
was Plato but Plato as a poet where he's
also the guy who's condemning the poets
and condemning the mesas and condemn it
condemning representation so how does he
actually fit in there that by the way
just to put in another plug for the
Nitra video that ties in with what
Nietzsche was saying hope they go on the
birth of tragedy so that was a lot of
fun you can see there was a lot of
teaching learning talks you know public
engagement kind of stuff going on in
February I also should he add to that my
wife saw the culmination of something
that she had put in four years of work
towards and that was bringing Temple
Grandin who you probably know about
she's a major researcher when it comes
to both the meat industry and with
respect to autism and learning styles
things like that they made a movie about
her she's at she's that famous my wife
brought her to the to the Culinary
Institute of America to do three days of
talks and and meet and greets and
dinners so that was really cool I
enjoyed getting to spend a little bit of
time with her and talk with her mainly
about prison education and about her
forecasts for where we're falling short
in terms of workplace training that was
that was really fun to pick her brain on
that but I was really proud of my wife
and I spent a good bit of time
supporting her on that because it was a
ton of work a ton of management of
little details so so good job to her
going back to februari stuff I shot a
number of videos and now pretty
pretty productive I'm actually having
trouble finding time slots to fit all
the minks I don't want to overwhelm
viewers the the religion in America
class we're using this textbook for that
that's ongoing and I've been shooting a
lot of video in class with that those
are the bulk of what I've been uploading
and releasing I also shot some
existentialism videos on Gabrielle
Marcel jean-paul Sartre I wanted to get
to more but I unfortunately I didn't I
did shoot a few of the 10 shorts videos
number 13 and number 14 both of which
had to do with questions in philosophy I
don't quite have enough questions for
some of the other things yet and so I'm
waiting before I release them to get a
few more questions on like education or
religion or you know things along those
lines I did a personal piece on anger
which is going to be followed up
eventually by a number of other pieces
having to do with anger which is one of
my areas of research and I'm very happy
to announce if you haven't seen it
already that I began a new series
somewhat a bit more more produced
although it's still pretty low tech
stuff on Hegel's phenomenology of spirit
and it's called half hour Hagel because
each of the videos is going to be you
know between 25 to 35 minutes or roughly
half an hour and what I'm doing is I'm
going through the entire phenomenology
of spirit paragraph by paragraph first
reading the text which usually takes
about a minute to read the paragraph
spending about anywhere from you know
five to fifteen minutes on commentary on
that telling you what Hagel's up to
they're using my chalkboard giving you a
little bit of the background he doesn't
name name so I tell you who we might be
you know having a mind at the time and
for me this is this is a project I've
been wanting to start on for quite a
while people have been asking me to
shoot more videos on Hagel and in my
view this is the way to do it I don't
want to skip over anything
if this is successful I think maybe I'll
start doing some other thinkers like
this as well but this is going to take a
while there's over 800 paragraphs in the
phenomenology each video will will
comprise maybe two or three paragraphs
so we're talking about at least 300
videos and if I release to a week that
means that it would take me at least a
year and a half probably closer to two
years of continual work on this which
I'm committed to because I think this is
a very important thing to do I think
there's not a lot of good quality
resources out there on Hagel and he is
somebody who people want to read and all
for that so what I can do to help out
with that you know if it takes me or
it's you know roughly on my part a five
to ten our commitment per week for the
next two years probably that so that's
that's what I'm doing I released the
first one and I have two more more or
less ready to go this week and I'm
shooting more material later on this
week so there's all of that um I also
did some other things having to do with
my professional life you know besides
public speaking and sort of doing
philosophy in a public way and besides
the YouTube videos I edited a piece that
I had written for a conference last year
on Anselm morality and in God for
publication eventually in the journal
questianus dis patate and I revised and
then submitted a paper which I
previously written and just sort of sat
on for a while to to a conference an
ethics conference another one on
handsome I can't tell you too much about
it I want to wait until it's actually
accepted but if it is then then you'll
see a video on it sometime in april and
i'll put a link to the paper itself so
that's februari
March we got a lot of cool stuff coming
up I'm not doing as much public speaking
at colleges and universities this month
but i am still continuing the library
talks i'm going to be talking about
Dostoevsky during the glimpses into
existence one that'll be march 29th so
if you're in the Hudson Valley area in
in New York and where you want to make a
day trip up from the city and you'd like
to hear a piece about Dostoevsky and get
to do some Q&A and some discussion i'll
be at the kingston library 1030 on
Saturday and March 29th i'm also doing
something like i mentioned before i'm
doing a meetup in kingston on sunday
march 16 and we're looking at doing
another dr. Sadler philosophy forum with
a friend and colleague of mine who I
know from from McIntyre circles he's a
really smart guy got some real good life
experience today's a fellow vet so we're
going to talk probably about some issues
in virtue ethics we don't haven't
completely worked out and I'm still
waiting to hear back from him about the
date so that's what's what's going on
with that I'm also going to be giving
some some footage some actually some
sound material to the punk rock
philosopher for his show having to do
with Friedrich Nietzsche's thus Spoke
Zarathustra and we'll see how that works
out I might do some some other things
this month as well but all of those
things are still just in planning so I'm
going to be doing a lot of video stuff
as well this this month I'm continuing
the religion in America class of course
there will be a few less videos because
we're actually going to have spring
break and we also have midterms coming
up so obviously I won't be shooting
video that day
allow me actually a chance to catch up
out there things I'm going to be doing
some more existentialism videos this
month I'm going to be focusing on Franz
Kafka simone de beauvoir and if I have
the time I want to do some more things
on Rilke the half hour Hagel videos you
can probably expect to see about seven
to eight of those coming out this month
so we're going to be a good ways into
the preface for the phenomenology I'm
really excited about that I might do
some more ten shorts videos if like I
said if I get some more questions about
those and if I have the time I'll shoot
some more material about anger but this
is going to be a pretty busy month
here's why I've got some other things
that aren't directly connected to videos
that are going to be fairly time
consuming I'm setting up the online
class with a player know which is very
close now to receiving accreditation and
very close to enrolling students I'm
working on an online existentialist
glass for a player know when it's
actually finished approved going live
I'll shoot a video about it basically
telling you what's going to be in the
course what we're going to do and
justifying why somebody might want to
pay five hundred dollars for a three
credit course in existentialist thought
with with me because it's it's a it's a
course that will actually be offered for
credit and will cost something and we'll
have a lot of really cool components if
this works a player know if a player
knows model actually works if it's
successful this could be a way in which
I might offer a lot of intensive courses
on the things that I'm I'm really
interested in teaching about and I would
make quite a bit more money than I do as
an adjunct teaching around here in part
because when you when you hire an
adjunct at a local university the
university is taking most of the money
and the adjunct is getting quite a
you know just a little bit of it it's
the opposite with a player know they are
deliberately setting things up so that
the the teacher gets the bulk of it and
they just take a little bit and so
things can be offered much more cheaply
and it can provide a what we call living
wage I'll be doing I but I know I've
been promising this for a while but this
is the month where I'm actually going to
produce some new curious lessons I've
really been behind on that but it's
something that I really want to get
going on like I said I'm doing this
collaboration with the punk rock
philosopher it was a radio show on
Saturday nights and we'll see how that
works out this is a new venture I'm not
sure exactly how it's going to pan out
but we'll give it a shot I am doing a
lot of writing this month a lot of
research a lot of sitting around reading
a lot of trying to get things set down
on paper in part because I need to write
a paper for a conference on the hook for
in April the saint anselm conference
which will be at st. Anselm College and
I'm writing a paper on an some marriage
and conjugal love I'm also trying to
work on a paper for the American
Catholic philosophical association the
deadline is at the end of this month and
it's being held not too far from here
down in Washington DC and the theme of
the conference this year is something
that I do a lot of work on virtues so
i'm going to write about that i'm also
trying to get some more work done on the
aristotle and anger book and on the ants
on the moral theory book my goal is to
actually like get a chapter in each of
those in decent shape because i've got a
lot of you know bits and pieces that
I've written here and there but they're
kind of their kind of scattered so I
want to sort of hunker down when it when
it comes to that and get those get some
momentum going on those again I'm also
putting together you know you may not
realize this but but
a lot of what I do is is providing
workshops and producing content and
producing resources that take philosophy
and and apply it to not only ordinary
people's lives but also to organizations
to education to the sort of big picture
things that people are talking about
like you know what's the nature of
happiness or what does it count to to
flourish as a human being or how should
we assess student learning or how can we
redesign processes and so that takes
quite a bit of work to take these
ancient philosophers and find ways to
adapt that to the present and then to
pitch workshops and talks to two
different institutions locally and
nationally but that's part of what I'm
engaged in that's part of what we do at
reason I oh I think with the video stuff
sometimes what you see is just kind of
the tip of the iceberg you might get you
might get a somewhat this total aside at
this point too by the way this isn't
about updates but you might get a
somewhat mistaken impression about just
what it is that that that I do with my
days by watching a few videos I you know
I'm a firm believer this is where all
those were all closed things I'm a firm
believer that that classical and
medieval philosophy contains all these
great resources that super brilliant
thinkers took lots of time to work out
and then were nice enough to pass down
to to the rest of us and that these
things are still relevant in our own
time they're really helpful for making
sense out of our lives but you got to do
a bit of work and it helps to have a
guide and some structure in order to try
to you know crack these nuts and get the
colonel out and then and then make them
your own make them part of your
existence of who you are and what you
want to do that's what I do that's my my
sort of mission that's what
my or are Andy's and mines consulting
company reason I oh that's what we're
about so this is a month of building in
part as well as all these other things
that we're talking about like shooting
lots of video and uploading and events
but this is this is sort of a month of
building I suppose it's kind of a app
that we're moving into spring coming out
of a winter of you know slow quiet
development and heading into a spring
where things are going to start speeding
up and a lot more things are going to be
happening the last thing I'll say is if
you're interested in hearing me me speak
at your institution your local library
or local college I would suggest
actually talking to them and saying hey
we'd like to bring this guy in to do a
talk about something all my information
is out there and I'm easy to contact you
can just you know email info at reason I
Oh calm and pitch something to me and if
it's within my realm of competence if
it's not I'll say I can't do that but
maybe I'll know somebody who can it's in
my realm of competence I'll certainly be
interested in talking further about
giving a talk or a workshop or producing
content